well our chief political correspondent
john craig is in westminster following
that just breaking then john what are
the details and uh what reaction has
there been so far well it's a
controversial trade deal just like the
one with australia because there will be
suspicions that yet again the government
is brushing aside environmental concerns
because after the australian deal uh it
was sky news revealed that the
environmental concerns were being swept
aside new zealand demanded the same deal
this time
it is a deal that mr johnson the prime
minister's done with uh jacinda arden in
principle during a video call and
according to the government it will cut
tariffs on british exports including
cars and clothes and new zealand imports
such as sauvignon wine manuka honey lamb
kiwi fruits now the
uh international trade secretary anne
marie tavatrovellian says there's
nothing for uk farmers to worry about
because she's the mp for barrick on
tweed she says it's good news for her
northumberland farmers the pm has said
this
this is great deal for the united
kingdom cementing our long friendship
with new zealand
and furthering our ties with the indos
pacific it will benefit businesses and
consumers across the country cutting
costs for exporters and opening up
access for our workers well despite the
claim by anne-marie trevelyan the nsu
president
minet batters has reacted angrily to
this deal she says the announcement of
this trade deal with new zealand coupled
with the australia deal signed earlier
this year means we'll be opening our
doors to significant extra volumes of
imported food whether or not produced to
our own high standards while securing
almost nothing in return for uk farmers
and she says we should all be worried
there could be a huge downside to these
deals especially for sectors such as
dairy red meat and horticulture we're
going to hear a lot more about those
protests from british farmers and no
doubt opposition mps on their behalf
over the next day or so
we'll look out for that john craig thank
you very much lead updating us there on
that new trade deal thank you